hello ladies and gentlemen Gregory Alba
is here yep and Jordan Ross Jordan Ross
from the channel cinematic cinematics
Jordan I know each other from many many
years ago over a decade over a decade we
lads where we did emotional memory yep
exercises oh yeah you and kid canceled
and I had to talk to my dad and you
elderlies oh you called me a lot of
[ __ ] that hit I would like go to him
you didn't really be me to mean because
you didn't want to actually like insult
maybe a so you're like well whatever you
you leprechaun and we were like trying
not to laugh while we were doing that
and I have a picture I don't know if I
sit dipti a sensory switch clothes yeah
that's pretty fun well we're on that
topic yeah Mel Gibson yeah men in the
news again lately not for bad things yes
movie coming out blood father yeah and a
few months hacks are Ridge direct
directing that I hope this could be the
start of a solid comeback maybe not like
the all defining come back from ya
Gibson but I feel like this could be a
good direction for him for sure I'm a
big Mel Gibson fan and I have defended
him through the public crisis is written
for the past few years Jordan I found
out really likes Mel Gibson to Manny
grew up on Mel Gibson just as much as
idea did you started rewatching Lethal
Weapon films recently i have my video
for lethal 11-5 yeah oh yeah the same
page you're on the same page and I just
want to do a video right now I just want
to catch in you know on before everyone
started saying I'm always getting
serious again serious cuz I know when
blood father hacks are rich comes out
people are gonna be like IO is really
not Gibson yeah yeah yeah we want to
make it clear right here right now yeah
we were headed always believed in milk
is yes even when he was saying stupid
stuff he shouldn't have been saying
we're not at all condoning like the
stuff that max is doing racism sexism
it's like that was bad but at the same
time you gotta you gotta consider the
fact that if all of us had our private
phone calls leaked to the public there'd
be some pretty bad stuff that you know
what
out there and it's not necessarily a
reflection of who we are as people or
what we truly believe sometimes when
you're mad and especially if you're
drunk or whatever you say and do some
really stupid things like if you guys do
actually take some time to do research
on what happens to your brain when you
get drunk yeah it is not the truth serum
as people make it melton yeah they're
like no you're than visits what you've
been repressing the whole dog yeah
that's not true that first off secondly
it's like these incidents that happen
like no it's not okay that you did down
but these are moments of anger and rage
yeah everyone knows anyone with a
logical mind knows that when people get
into a feeling of anger and rage we tend
to say things we're down the road were
like I'm sorry yeah I've said yeah I
love my wife more than anyone and we've
gotten an army it's like we fought all
the time but it's like we've been
together for six years so it's like
we've had fights there's things that
I've said that I didn't mean at all yeah
but when you're in the moment and you're
just seeing red you say thing where it's
like you don't think about it you're
just things protect it's not how I true
and then you feel justified in the
moment cuz you're so here ya say [ __ ]
that you're like no this is right yeah
but then down later on especially with
no gifts like none of these incidents
that he's had just to cover like this
[ __ ] real fast ya know the incidence
he's had have been just him angry no you
know like he's drunk you know he's
alcoholism struggles yeah alcoholism
struggles are very real thing in this
world of sickness it's a sickness yeah
it's a disease these instances have
these were private moments yeah well not
at all meant to be displayed towards the
public now not saying that makes it okay
but look ask yourself for a second i'm
sure is an internet person who is
commented on videos yeah I will [ __ ]
murder this person yeah this guy can go
kill anticancer yeah yeah all that [ __ ]
imagine if you said it to someone in
person or on the phone yeah I'll be like
that's like an abusive man yeah there's
there's things that we've all done
behind closed doors that we would never
do or say in public and it's just not an
all defining thing about one human being
when I'm like at a table and people are
like Will Smith is an [ __ ] I'm like
what where'd you get this information i
buy one
yeah I was a dick yeah I'm like see the
sure Will Smith just wasn't having like
a bad day or something right yeah
exactly like there must be people that
love him if you were to get this far la
différence and same thing with mel
gibson like that must be people that
like love him for a reason like what you
were saying and I've read a lot of
interns and what people have come out
and spoken saying to like I've worked
him plenty of times yeah great human
being that thing that Robert Downey jr.
did when yeah he dedicated his whole
acceptance speech to Mel Gibson and he
wants him to direct a marble yeah and
like yeah I'm the most powerful guys in
Hollywood right now Robert Downey jr.
and if anyone understands making
mistakes and having to make a comeback
it's Robert down did you judge for
moments that got revealed to the public
life and then that to be a stamp as this
is who you are permanent yeah now in the
public's eye it's just [ __ ]
ridiculous to go and judge someone based
off a public one made one action
separate Kanye West yeah I'll be a dick
in real life I was just like giving up
on it because the thing that bugs me is
that Mel Gibson before that everyone
loved him he was one of the most beloved
actors in Hollywood then he makes a
mistake he had a moment of weakness not
that it excuses it but he had a moment
of weakness and his career for the last
decade or so it was pretty much don't
get hard and rough career yeah so but
it's like there's people like Kanye or
Miley Cyrus or the Kardashians remember
zoom around yeah that do and say crazy
things and some you know there's actors
and and celebrities that have done
terrible things but they still remain in
the limelight they still remain admired
and a huge topic of conversation and
their careers live on but Mel Gibson
who's a great actor and by most accounts
a really good person had made a mistake
and then his career was was ruined me is
not to give given like a significant
amount of his money to charity sxy for
just some gung-ho about giving as much
as i canna charity and I'm not Catholic
no but I think it's kind of beautiful
this guy is very devoted to his faith
and for a guy to be my man of faith is a
big deal in Hollywood yeah especially
not like your faith is hardening yeah
it's almost taboo in Hollywood to talk
about your faith but it's like having
someone like like Mel Gibson that's you
know that's really strong in his faith
and has strong opinions and stuff even
if you disagree it's admirable when he
said that drunken
and he mentioned that comment about you
know Jews yeah [ __ ] and stuff like I
see why that was of such a big deal
because sure like there's that
stereotype in Hollywood about how the
lot of Jewish people are like run and
it's a its vigorous accurate that's not
that's not fun but for people like judge
him off the phone calls so much yeah
there was some suffering that it was not
okay but if we just heard that he had
those phone calls yeah that would have
been it yeah that would have been it but
because we heard the actual yes we
suddenly feel like we know this person
is who you really like I just [ __ ] up
because I think about like people like
Chris Brown when they revealed the court
case or hearing him all the details of
what happened you nearly killed Rihanna
if we had like 10 seconds of him hitting
Rihanna like on a video yeah then his
whole career doomed yeah but because we
heard about it no video footage we can
forget about yeah yeah now and it's like
that's just what happened with him and
the end of the day though this is a guy
who works in a field of imagination of
our 10 of art not to represent his real
life it's kind of how I feel about Tom
Cruise like people judging so much off
the Scientology [ __ ] I'm not a
Scientologist and do I really support it
I really have an opinion on it girly but
I love Tom Cruise's work I think he's an
amazing actor I think he's really good I
here's a great human being to other that
was what fit he's a hard worker so hard
to for positive yeah yeah and Mel Gibson
same thing it's like this guy is he's
Olympus a Hollywood legend and it's so
sad to see what's happened as of late to
just look over the works that Mel's done
mad mad mad mad mad max fury but it's
like the most Hale movie he has a guy
who like started man man yeah you
started Mad Max for Mad Max had a budget
yeah you know yeah it was it was just as
good yeah it was still awesome and
because of him and still like to this
day like fury road shines more on
supporting characters than mad max yes
so I still walk away from for you're
going well get Mel Gibson didn't warm
accident grunt exact the lethal weapon
movies for example
then mammals air America yeah no but a
bird on a wire yeah he really has done
some some really really great movies and
it's been a part of some really iconic
franchises and like Braveheart the
Patriot we were soldiers you know all
these epic war movie was great at
choosing big-budget movies where he
could deliver great performance yeah
something rare for actors so truly yeah
cuz I'm a lot of actors like I do the
big-budget movies for the money but then
I did the indie projects or the
performance yeah but then you see a
hundred million dollar plus maybe like
the patriot and I find myself crying
twice in that movie it's a movie that
seemed with like that last moment with
eep ledger in that movie yeah I walked
in 20 minutes before that happened like
the first time I saw the moon yeah and I
was crying no yeah it's it's it's such a
good movie in the ransom oh my god
that's again the green oh yeah the more
reasonable that's the other thing too is
that beyond his past work since the
incidence has happened he still
delivered griya [ __ ] work even if
it's not getting the same recognition as
his fast work the beaver beaver Rick
he's a mother it wasn't an action movie
at all yeah but that's the thing he's
not only a great action star he's a
great actor yeah I don't consider him an
action sorry I feel like a lot of the
world considers it yeah former action
yeah I feel I know Mel Gibson as an
amazing act like ransoms on an action
movie there's thrills but he's great
Bravehearts not an action movie he's
great corrected it [ __ ] brilliant you
laid it to the real William Wallace to
like I was elated really yes sir he has
a personal thing that's the movie that
got me to be a huge fan of Mel Gibson
when I was a little kid I watched that
because my grandma told me I'm related
to William Wallace and that was one of
my all-time favorite movies and then
from then on I've you know been a
die-hard medicine man you know he became
out with edge of darkness which I know
wasn't he how that's the greatest film
but because a woman's daughter killed
his daughter still you'll spoil a
mission well that's blown out
expendables 3 comes out no one really
likes it got everyone's like Mel
Gibson's really should break back oh
yeah machete kills comes out people
don't really like it the last 30 minutes
Mel Gibson is a great job
he's making this comeback now he has
blood father coming out my father coming
out which I'm excited for it looks
strong rage looks weird and every day
what father currently has like eighty
percent eighty-five percent on rotten
tomatoes yeah and which I'm excited to
see that yeah and with hacksaw rich
coming outs like yeah I feel like this
could be Mel Gibson's like the beginning
of the comeback yeah and it was just
announced that I think it's called the
professor in the madman it stars mel
gibson and sean penn they've both been
attached to star I know they've been
friends yeah this whole ordeal yeah and
Sean Penn's another guy who's done some
you know questionable things do it tie
down and beat me dog I think he did yeah
I mean and that's that's another guy or
it's like it's a terrible thing but it's
like you know he's still his career
still going but Mel Gibson discuss means
we didn't see it like Robert Downey jr.
Mickey Rourke Sean Penn have all been
able to break away from their public and
a personal life instances because they
were never as high as Mel Gibson ever
was his bill Houston was like the top of
the line I might have been the biggest
star it like at least top like five and
if you go to like there was a while you
go to like go to celebrities and it's
like Tom Cruise Brad Pitt Mel Gibson I
think that's why Mel Gibson's fall was
so publicized because he was one of the
top dudes exactly he's proven himself
enough I know he's gone to rehab and
it's none of my [ __ ] business I it's
not my business if I dude I love your
work and I just want you to keep on
working to do it and I think it's unfair
to judge someone so much as if we really
know the real them yeah cuz I can't
imagine what it's like to be that famous
no I have over a little over four
hundred thousand subs right now yeah I
get a lot of comments and I get
recognized maybe once a week which is
awesome then I think about what if it
was like that all the time what if I was
Mel Gibson so hard to just you know
recenter yourself and like okay so let's
go to in and out yeah yeah yeah I can't
go somewhere live your life but ya gotta
like constantly being hiding and
constantly gotta be your Venture there's
gonna be a buildup yeah repress [ __ ]
from having to constantly hide stuff and
all stuff in like it's going to happen I
think like if anything try to understand
why you might have had an explosion yeah
instead of just going exploded horrible
human being and I've talked to people
that have met him and work
with him and if you want to get a real
cuz like with celebrities it's easy to
act like we know them because we have
see them in the tabloids and stuff like
that if you want to really get a feel
for the kind of person someone as you
talk to the people that are close to
them ya know them and that it were real
people and people that Madame yeah timer
saw him do something or heard something
yeah and I've heard one story like some
of you may not know my grandpas an actor
his name's Barry Corbin he's done a lot
so you know I've talked to a lot of
people within the industry yeah I've
been in the industry for a while as well
and a lot of people have talked to that
have worked with Mel Gibson none of them
have said anything bad about him they've
all talked about how he's a good guy and
here's one of the best people who work
with onset this year before the
businesses do that people have said like
he is one of the most fun people to work
yeah he knows how to create a very
positive vibe yeah especially when he's
behind the camera he still knows how to
create a vibe that is like you feel fun
to create you give it one of the best
film adaptations of Hamlet he gave his
performance he learned the Shakespearean
language there he get fluently but I
heard him between takes you would like
moon people just to lighten up the size
I really feel that like this is his time
yeah what's happened has happened that
doesn't mean it has to define him
forever and let's just have a look at
what he has to offer us now and I like
old book yeah I me too he's like what
ready oh look it's like Kurt Russell
with yeah he did like big trouble little
china escape from new york all that
stuff back in the 80s he didn't do a
whole lot for a while but now he's
coming back with hateful eight bone
tomahawk guardians the galaxy two and
he's making this like it when actors
embrace their older me chair looking
image yeah just rough halsted i'm trying
to like let me put as much to botox and
everything yeah to prevent myself from
looking over you know like mel gibson's
like i'm gonna grow the beard out gonna
get the old we go yeah he just looks
cool oh yeah he's a man he's still got
it i can't wait till I'm old it he's
still got his really cool voice to ya
that voice that was once Australia
turned America yeah yeah and my mom
loves Mel Gibson my mom I used to go to
my mom's office and she had a birthday
party once surprise birthday from her
coworkers it was plastered every wall
and I some photos Mel Gibson no Gibson
though I love you still and I'm gonna
watch blood father
opening night this is your [ __ ] better
let me say it would come back and I want
to tell everyone that I was there yep
day one for you buddy we've never left
your side mal never left your side I had
an acting teacher tell me once that
every successful actor goes through five
stages maybe even more than once first
is who I'm just gonna say my name for
example who is Jordan Ross and then it's
get me Jordan Ross and then it's get me
a Jordan Ross tight yeah and then it's
get me a younger Jordan sauce and then
it's whatever happened to George its
kind of Mel Gibson's kind of gone
through that ok really on it it's like
whatever happened to Mel Gibson and now
it's coming back where it's like get me
Mel Gibson yeah so he's making this come
back cuz at the end of the day no one
could do what he can do no no one could
do it no he's he is he is such as a nap
just acting he has one of the most
natural sounding actors ya ever never
sounds like he like is acting at know it
just sounds like he's talking me yeah
uni understands how to work within genre
really well yes send a worker Russell
like you were saying yeah like they're
great genre genre to genre there just is
like what women want i watch them it's
hilarious good idea it's a funny movie
navra he's great ya ever yeah like you
know he can do anything a lot of people
don't appreciate that enough and we
disagree we deserve that talent to be
out there stuff yeah especially dance
he's he's not that old so yeah guys
that's our defense from mel gibson yeah
drive to the real rechecks jordan has
his movie channel cinematics yes as if
you're addicted to cinema go there yeah
if you consider yourself a true movie
buff go there now do it and shout out to
um Mel Gibson Oh Gibson's kids yeah of
all ed you were happy yeah I wish I was
since I was stretching at him and I'm
gonna read was dressed i bet i was one
of his seven sons yeah hopefully he
noticed me